This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers, now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit, and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you. High in caffeine, details at McDonald's.cai at participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。全新的红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，由冷冻干燥水果制成，带来爆发性的电感风味。全新的红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合您。咖啡因含量高，详情请见McDonalds.ca，参与活动的加拿大餐厅除魁北克外均有销售。
I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我从九个月的囚禁中幸存下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会与那些经历过不可思议之事、被绑架、被跟踪、被控制、几乎被噤声的幸存者在一起。这些故事讲述了如何才能活着走出来。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。
On the new podcast, Solita, we share the message. reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Your bookshelf and your for you page are equally important to your personality. Welcome home.
在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享作为女性独自旅行的真实信息。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个陌生人主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“是”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性来交换怜悯。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》。您的书架和您的推荐页面对您的个性同样重要。欢迎回家。
Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and love island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of women's health and gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause.
《Pro Society》是一档每周播出的播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》具有同等讨论价值的人。每周，我们都会与您最喜欢的作家、读书博主以及大量深思熟虑的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化联系起来。是的，我着迷了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。欢迎来到《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特医生，纽约市Atria健康研究所女性健康与妇科主席。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并直接为您带来关于中年女性健康的重要信息。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。
Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to Decoding Women's Health with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. You guys know the drill. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I have a mini bite-sized episode for you all. This is part of our broader debunking psychology series we've been doing recently where
即使它是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它呢？请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特医生的《解码女性健康》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。你们知道流程。很高兴你们能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理。今天，我为大家准备了一个迷你短篇。这是我们最近一直在做的更广泛的“揭秘心理学”系列的一部分，其中
we take popular psychology terms, popular psychology phrases that have become widely used in society, sometimes misused, and we break down exactly what they mean and the real evidence-based science and history that most people just don't know. We've covered personality tests. We've done Stockholm Syndrome, trauma buns, narcissism, and today we turn our attention to one of the biggest of them all, which is the Oedipus Complex. You have probably heard about the Oedipus Complex in TV shows, comedy routines, newspaper headlines, gossip magazines, everyday conversations, and you may know it means something
我们选取了在社会中被广泛使用、有时被误用的流行心理学术语和短语，并剖析它们的确切含义，以及大多数人根本不知道的基于证据的真实科学和历史。我们已经讨论过人格测试。我们讨论过斯德哥尔摩综合症、创伤纽带、自恋，今天我们将注意力转向其中最大的一个，即俄狄浦斯情结。你可能在电视节目、喜剧表演、报纸头条、八卦杂志、日常对话中听说过俄狄浦斯情结，你可能知道它意味着某种
raunchy. You may have an idea that it means something to do with maybe sex, maybe some other, are rated themes, but today I really just want to break it down entirely for you. A quick disclaimer, this episode talks about sex and it talks about sexual attraction in a kind of, in a strange and not always pleasant to discuss context. I'm going to say it that way. This is purely for educational purposes. but if you are sensitive to topics around sex and around attraction and children,
下流的东西。你可能认为它与性有关，或者与某些其他成人主题有关，但今天我真的只是想为你彻底剖析它。快速免责声明，这一集讨论性，并以一种奇怪且不总是令人愉快的讨论语境讨论性吸引力。我就这么说吧。这纯粹是为了教育目的。但如果你对围绕性、吸引力和儿童的话题敏感，
it may be best to skip this episode. As I said, all educational, but sometimes a little bit sensitive. So let's get into it. So to begin with, let's just cover the basics. What is the Oedipus Complex? What does it mean? How did it originate? So, the Oedipus Complex describes a conflict that Sigmund Freud believed emerged during early childhood.
最好跳过这一集。正如我所说，全是教育性的，但有时有点敏感。那么让我们开始吧。首先，让我们涵盖基础知识。什么是俄狄浦斯情结？它意味着什么？它是如何起源的？所以，俄狄浦斯情结描述了西格蒙德·弗洛伊德认为在幼儿期出现的冲突。
In its most familiar form, the Oedipus Complex is basically this idea that a young boy develops an unconscious sexual or romantic desire for his mother. And as a result of that, begins to view his father, who in this kind of form already occupies the position beside her, as a rival. It's important to stress the word unconscious here. So Freud, the person who first began speaking about this idea and gave it its name, he wasn't claiming that four-year-olds consciously sit there and think about entering a sexual relationship with their mothers. Instead, he kind of believed these wishes existed beneath our conscious awareness and appeared indirectly. So appeared through things like intense affection for one's mother, possessiveness, jealousy, fantasy, and competition with the father.
在最熟悉的形式中，俄狄浦斯情结基本上是这样一种观点：一个小男孩对他母亲产生了潜意识的性或浪漫欲望。结果，他开始将已经占据她身边位置的父亲视为竞争对手。在这里强调“潜意识”这个词很重要。所以弗洛伊德，那个最早开始谈论这个想法并给它命名的人，他并不是声称四岁的孩子有意识地坐在那里思考与母亲建立性关系。相反，他认为这些愿望存在于我们的意识之下，并间接地出现。所以通过对母亲强烈的爱、占有欲、嫉妒、幻想和与父亲的竞争等事物表现出来。
You know, when a child becomes irritated or annoyed because the dad is kissing the mom, like Freud interpreted that as symbolic. Or when a child, so specifically a boy child in this scenario, when he's saying, you know, I want to marry mommy when I grow up. Again, Freud saw that as indicative of the Oedipus complex. unconscious desire for the mother and an unconscious competition with the father. Because of these unconscious desires, the child experiences a weird kind of strange situation where they both rely on their mother but also love her in a strange way.
你知道，当一个孩子因为爸爸亲吻妈妈而变得烦躁或恼火时，弗洛伊德将其解释为象征性的。或者当一个孩子，在这个场景中特指男孩，当他说，你知道，我长大后想娶妈妈。同样，弗洛伊德认为这表明了俄狄浦斯情结。对母亲的潜意识欲望和对父亲的潜意识竞争。由于这些潜意识的欲望，孩子经历了一种奇怪的情况，他们既依赖母亲，又以一种奇怪的方式爱她。
And then they also rely on their father but feel competition and fear for him in the same way. They believe, well, according to Freud, he believed that when a young boy begins to see their mother this way, they believe that if their father were to find out about it, they would hurt them or harm them. And so they also feel all these very complex relationships towards what are actually their caregivers and the people who need to take care of them. So this combination of love and hostility and fear creates the psychological conflict that is at the center of the complex. in Freud's mind there was this kind of four-way pathway going on where a child or a boy loves their mother also loves their father desires their mother is jealous of the father and is fearful of the father so this is the basic premise let's talk about where Freud got this idea from because if we're being honest it's a pretty weird idea like every everything I say
然后他们也依赖父亲，但以同样的方式感到竞争和恐惧。他们认为，好吧，根据弗洛伊德的说法，他认为当一个小男孩开始这样看待他们的母亲时，他们认为如果他们的父亲发现了，他们会伤害他们。所以他们也对实际上是他们的照顾者和需要照顾他们的人产生了所有这些非常复杂的关系。因此，这种爱、敌意和恐惧的结合创造了处于情结中心的心理冲突。在弗洛伊德看来，有一种四向路径，孩子或男孩爱他们的母亲，也爱他们的父亲，渴望他们的母亲，嫉妒父亲，并害怕父亲。所以这就是基本前提，让我们谈谈弗洛伊德从哪里得到这个想法，因为如果我们诚实的话，这是一个相当奇怪的想法，就像我说的每一件事
about this part of me is like oh I need to just double clarify that this is not my belief this is a belief of long, long ago that I think in the modern day we kind of just look at and say is very creepy and unnecessary. However, it has a historical role and it is a theory that exists, so where did it come from? So the Oedipus Complex came about through a combination of Freud's clinical work with adult patients, his interpretations of their dreams and their symptoms. he read a lot into literature and mythology. And he also based this theory on his own self-analysis.
关于我这一部分的说法就像是，哦，我需要再次澄清，这不是我的信仰，这是一个很久很久以前的信仰，我认为在现代，我们只是看着它并说它非常令人毛骨悚然且不必要。然而，它有一个历史角色，它是一个存在的理论，那么它来自哪里呢？所以俄狄浦斯情结是通过弗洛伊德与成年患者的临床工作、他对他们的梦和症状的解释而产生的。他阅读了大量的文学和神话。他还基于自己的自我分析来建立这个理论。
So based on how he fell about his mother and how he felt about his father. Very important to clarify. This theory did not come from any kind of official study, experiment, or any kind of structured scientific research. It is what we would call a singular anecdotal. theory coming from the mind of one person. So I said that he did a lot of self-analysis about this. Well, it was actually the death of his father in 1896 that really triggered Freud to start thinking about this and he really began reflecting upon his own childhood and his attachment to his mother and his feelings towards his father. Essentially, this man had a lot of really deep
所以基于他对他母亲的感受以及他对他父亲的感受。非常重要的一点是澄清。这个理论并非来自任何形式的官方研究、实验或任何形式的结构化科学研究。这就是我们所说的单一轶事。来自一个人思想的理论。所以我说他对此做了很多自我分析。好吧，实际上是他父亲在1896年的去世真正触发了弗洛伊德开始思考这个问题，他真的开始反思自己的童年以及他对母亲的依恋和对父亲的感受。本质上，这个男人有很多非常深刻的
wounds to do with his parents. And he obviously had a lot of really weird feelings about his parents, as is indicated by his creation of this Oedipus complex idea. And unlike the normal person who would have these experiences and say, that's a bit weird, that's probably something for me to deal with. He said, well, I think everybody else must feel this way as well. And I think this must be a thing that every single young boy goes through. This is a theory of human development that we haven't figured out yet. And so I'm talking about it for the first time. Now, the name Edipus and the story of Edipus that gave this complex, its name, is a lot older than Freud's theory. As I said, Freud, you know, we see him as this like researcher
与父母有关的创伤。而且他显然对父母有很多非常奇怪的感受，正如他创造这个俄狄浦斯情结的想法所表明的那样。而且不像普通人会经历这些并说，这有点奇怪，这可能是我需要处理的事情。他说，好吧，我想其他人一定也有这种感觉。而且我认为这一定是每个小男孩都会经历的事情。这是一个我们还没有弄清楚的人类发展理论。所以我第一次谈论它。现在，俄狄浦斯这个名字和赋予这个情结名字的俄狄浦斯故事，比弗洛伊德的理论要古老得多。正如我所说，弗洛伊德，你知道，我们把他看作是这种研究者
scientist. He kind of also just really liked history and he really liked Greek mythology. And so when he was looking for a name for this complex that he'd identified, he went to that same source. He went back to Greek mythology. And of course, he found the perfect story. story of Edipus. If you are not familiar with it, in the story, Edipus, the character, the main character, is told by an oracle that he is destined to kill his father and to marry his mother. Now, this prophecy wasn't just given to Oedipus himself, but was delivered years earlier to his biological parents. And his biological parents were this very famous king and queen. And so when they were told that story when he
科学家。他也确实非常喜欢历史，也非常喜欢希腊神话。所以当他为他确定的这个情结寻找名字时，他去了同一个来源。他回到了希腊神话。当然，他找到了完美的故事。俄狄浦斯的故事。如果你不熟悉它，在故事中，俄狄浦斯，这个角色，主角，被神谕告知他注定要杀死他的父亲并娶他的母亲。现在，这个预言不仅是给俄狄浦斯本人的，而且是在几年前传达给他亲生父母的。而他的亲生父母是非常著名的国王和王后。所以当他们被告知那个故事时，当他
was born, they wanted to prevent it. So they ordered that the infant be killed. they ordered that their son, Oedipus, you know, be murdered. Instead, he wasn't murdered. He was abandoned on a mountainside and he was found and he was raised by another family completely unaware of his true origins. He later receives the prophecy, but he believes the people who he knows as his mother and father are his real mother and father. And so he tries to escape his fate by fleeing them, by avoiding them. But in his efforts to do that, he, as he is, he is, he tries to escape his fate. And so he, he tries to escape his fate by by avoiding them. But in his efforts to do that,
出生时，他们想阻止它。所以他们下令杀死这个婴儿。他们下令他们的儿子，俄狄浦斯，你知道，被谋杀。相反，他没有被谋杀。他被遗弃在山坡上，被另一个家庭发现并抚养长大，完全不知道他真正的出身。他后来收到了预言，但他相信他所知道的母亲和父亲是他真正的母亲和父亲。所以他试图通过逃离他们、避开他们来逃避他的命运。但在他努力做到这一点时，他，正如他所是，他试图逃避他的命运。所以他，他试图逃避他的命运，通过避开他们。但在他努力做到这一点时，
he, as he is fleeing, he encounters an old man at a crossroad, on a road. They have a heated argument. He kills him. That man is his father. He doesn't know that. He thinks his father is back in his hometown.
他，正如他逃离时那样，在十字路口，在路上遇到了一位老人。他们发生了激烈的争吵。他杀了他。那个人是他的父亲。他不知道这一点。他以为他的父亲还在他的家乡。
And he then travels to Thebes where he solves this riddle. And the result of him solving this riddle is that he gets to assume the throne and take the hand of the widowed queen. he marries her, not realizing that the widow queen is in fact his mother. And so the prophecy comes true. You know, when it's finally revealed, it's very sad. Edipus blinds himself, his mother slash wife, dies by suicide. So it's just very dramatic. It's this big Greek story. And Freud heard that story, and he was like, that, I'm going to steal that. That sounds great. But also he thought, well, there's a reason this story must be so popular. It must be so popular because a lot of people relate to it.
然后他前往底比斯，在那里他解开了这个谜题。他解开这个谜题的结果是他得以继承王位并娶了那位寡居的王后。他娶了她，没有意识到那位寡居的王后实际上是他的母亲。所以预言成真了。你知道，当它最终被揭露时，非常悲伤。俄狄浦斯弄瞎了自己，他的母亲兼妻子自杀身亡。所以这非常戏剧性。这是一个伟大的希腊故事。弗洛伊德听到了那个故事，他想，那个，我要偷走它。听起来不错。但也认为，好吧，这个故事一定如此受欢迎是有原因的。它一定如此受欢迎，因为很多人与它产生共鸣。
So he kind of saw our interest in a story like that as a projection of an unconscious internal desire. So that's where the name Oedipus complex came from. So to understand why Freud thought this particular conflict emerged in early childhood, we also need to look at his broader theory of psychosexual development. So Freud divided childhood development into a sequence of stages. During each stage, he believed the libido, which for him, libido was not all about sex. It was also about, you know, the psychic energy of life and the pleasure-seeking energy of the human spirit.
所以他把我们对这样一个故事的兴趣看作是一种潜意识内在欲望的投射。这就是俄狄浦斯情结这个名字的由来。为了理解为什么弗洛伊德认为这种特殊的冲突出现在幼儿期，我们还需要看看他更广泛的性心理发展理论。所以弗洛伊德将儿童发展分为一系列阶段。在每个阶段，他认为力比多，对他来说，力比多不仅仅是关于性。它也关于，你知道，生命的心理能量和人类精神的快乐寻求能量。
Sex was involved. Not, wasn't everything. Like when we think of libido today, we just think sexual desire. No, for him it meant life. It meant energy. He believed that in each stage, our libido became focused upon a particular bodily area or developmental conflict. So as we moved through childhood, we move through these stages. was the oral stage, which is associated with the mouth and feeding. There is the anal stage,
性参与其中。不是，不是全部。就像我们今天想到力比多时，我们只想到性欲。不，对他来说，它意味着生命。它意味着能量。他认为在每个阶段，我们的力比多都集中在特定的身体区域或发展冲突上。所以当我们经历童年时，我们经历这些阶段。是口腔期，与嘴巴和喂养有关。有肛门期，
which is associated with bowel control, the phallic stage, the latency period, and finally, the genital stage, which Freud associated with more, like, mature sexuality. Now, the Oedipus complex was supposed to reach its peak during the phallic stage, which is around three to six years old. During this period, Freud believed children became especially interested in their bodies. They became very interested in, like, their anatomical features and how the sexes, differed in that way. And he kind of saw that as that they were, I don't know, he really read a lot into that in a way that we probably wouldn't today. For us, we kind of understand that children are curious because they are learning. Freud took that a whole step further and was like,
与肠道控制有关，性器期，潜伏期，最后是生殖期，弗洛伊德将其与更成熟的性行为联系起来。现在，俄狄浦斯情结应该在性器期达到顶峰，即三到六岁左右。在此期间，弗洛伊德认为儿童对自己的身体变得特别感兴趣。他们对，你知道，他们的解剖特征以及性别在那种方式上的差异变得非常感兴趣。他有点认为那是他们，我不知道，他确实以一种我们今天可能不会的方式对此进行了大量的解读。对我们来说，我们有点理解孩子好奇是因为他们在学习。弗洛伊德更进一步，认为，
this curiosity must reflect a sexual desire within the family and this idea that children are, you know, it just got very, very strange. So in his mind, And he thought that as children, specifically boys, went through this period, that is when they experienced this conflict between, you know, wanting their mother, hating their father. And the only way for them to get through that conflict was to realize that they couldn't have their mother and therefore they should become like their father to find somebody like their mother later on in life. They begin to emulate their father.
这种好奇心一定反映了家庭内部的性欲，以及这种孩子是，你知道，它变得非常非常奇怪。所以在他的脑海里。他认为当孩子，特别是男孩，经历这个时期时，那是他们经历这种冲突的时候，你知道，想要他们的母亲，恨他们的父亲。他们度过这种冲突的唯一方法是意识到他们不能拥有他们的母亲，因此他们应该变得像他们的父亲，以便在以后的生活中找到像他们母亲那样的人。他们开始效仿他们的父亲。
They begin to copy him. this is called identification and it's how boys learn to be men, it's how they learn what's right in society. In practice, he was like, well, this is why, and this really explains why boys go through this period of really loving their mothers, being very much like mother-orientated to wanting to be like their fathers and suddenly taking an interest in the same activities as them, imitating them, wanting to dress like them, wanting to be around them all the time. That, to most of us would just be like, that's how children learn. They learn through socialization. They learn through experiences and modeling. Freud was like, well, no, it's because like they're sexually
他们开始模仿他。这被称为认同，这是男孩学习成为男人的方式，这是他们学习社会中什么是正确的方式。在实践中，他认为，好吧，这就是为什么，这确实解释了为什么男孩会经历这个非常爱母亲的时期，非常以母亲为导向，到想要变得像父亲，并突然对与他们相同的活动产生兴趣，模仿他们，想要像他们一样穿衣，想要一直和他们在一起。那，对我们大多数人来说，只是，那是孩子学习的方式。他们通过社会化学习。他们通过经验和建模学习。弗洛伊德认为，好吧，不，这是因为他们对母亲有性
attracted to their mother. And that's just where it gets very, very strange. But he did say by resolving the Oedipus complex, this is important for people, specifically boys, to learn social order to learn what is right, what is wrong, and to learn more about who they are and who they want to be. That is the outcome if it's resolved. Again, this is unconscious. So he says that even as boys get older, they never, they don't really realize that they ever had these desires. It just kind of is something that pushes them and shapes them and moves them forward. However, the desire never really goes away. So this is this interesting thing. Freud was like, well, in order to resolve and to become, like, in order to become more mature and to develop,
吸引。这就是它变得非常非常奇怪的地方。但他确实说，通过解决俄狄浦斯情结，这对人们，特别是男孩，学习社会秩序，学习什么是对的，什么是错的，并更多地了解他们是谁以及他们想成为谁，是很重要的。如果解决了，这就是结果。同样，这是潜意识的。所以他说，即使男孩长大后，他们也从未，他们并没有真正意识到他们曾经有过这些欲望。它只是某种推动他们、塑造他们并推动他们前进的东西。然而，欲望从未真正消失。所以这是这个有趣的事情。弗洛伊德认为，好吧，为了解决并变得，就像，为了变得更成熟并发展，
one should resolve this desire for the mother. But additionally, he also said, well, one actually never does, though. One never does. He basically believed that, you know, it just becomes more suppressed. And then it comes up later when a boy goes to choose his own life partner. And it's why he believed and why a lot of people will kind of have this, there's this weird myth in society that, you know, boys choose somebody who's just like their mom. And all of that comes back to the Oedipus complex.
一个人应该解决这种对母亲的欲望。但此外，他还说，好吧，一个人实际上从未这样做过，尽管如此。一个人从未这样做过。他基本上认为，你知道，它只是变得更加压抑。然后当一个男孩去选择他自己的人生伴侣时，它就会出现。这就是为什么他认为，以及为什么很多人会有一种，社会上有一种奇怪的神话，你知道，男孩选择一个就像他们妈妈一样的人。所有这些都回到了俄狄浦斯情结。
Now, that's what happens if it's resolved, i.e. boys still unconsciously want someone like their mom, doesn't sound resolved to me. But if it was unresolved and if the boy never learned to give up this unconscious desire and never learned to identify with the father, what Freud believed happened was that they developed a fixation or they became emotionally and developmentally frozen at this point in their life. And what that meant was that even as they get older, a man or a boy who has not resolved this conflict will become very frustrated, will really have difficulties with authority, have difficulties with jealousy and possessiveness and romantic relationships. So it's an important developmental stage for boys to go through. That is the basic
现在，如果它解决了，即男孩仍然潜意识地想要一个像他们妈妈一样的人，那听起来对我来说并不像解决了。但如果它没有解决，如果男孩从未学会放弃这种潜意识的欲望，从未学会认同父亲，弗洛伊德认为发生的事情是他们产生了固着，或者他们在人生的这一点上在情感和发展上冻结了。这意味着即使他们长大后，一个没有解决这种冲突的男人或男孩会变得非常沮丧，在权威方面会有真正的困难，在嫉妒和占有欲以及浪漫关系方面会有困难。所以这对男孩来说是一个重要的发展阶段。这就是基本
summary and basic theory that came from Freud's brain. Does it have any evidence? This theory is quite an old one and our scientific standards and abilities and testing functions have improved. With that, have we ever been able to find support for this theory that Freud couldn't when he was alive? Let's talk about it after this short break. The new Red Bull Dragonberry and Tropicberry Energizers now at McDonald's, made with freeze-dried fruit and an electric burst of flavor. The all-new Red Bull Energizers, now at McDonald's. This product may not be right for you.
总结和来自弗洛伊德大脑的基本理论。它有任何证据吗？这个理论相当古老，我们的科学标准、能力和测试功能已经提高。有了这些，我们是否曾经能够找到支持这个理论的证据，而弗洛伊德在世时却找不到？让我们在短暂休息后谈谈。全新的红牛龙莓和热带莓能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市，由冷冻干燥水果制成，带来爆发性的电感风味。全新的红牛能量饮料，现已在麦当劳上市。本产品可能不适合您。
Caffeine details at McDonald's.ca. At participating Canadian restaurants, excluding Quebec. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me.
咖啡因详情请见McDonalds.ca。在参与活动的加拿大餐厅，不包括魁北克。当我14岁时，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我幸存了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边那个低沉、嘲弄的声音说，闭嘴，什么都别说。每周我都会与那些经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起。我知道如果他醒来，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。
I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B.
我开始感觉到床尾有人，我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。但这些不是关于他们被夺走什么的故事。这是关于如何才能活着走出来的故事。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。在新的播客《Solita》中，我们分享作为女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个陌生人主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。
I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us. Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is and not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first. trip. I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“是”。我的使命是重新定义“solita”这个词，用可能性来交换怜悯。每次我试图独处时，我都会遇到人，他们会说，你对我们笑了。这里没有多少人笑。当你独处时，你最能接受世界本来的样子，而不是别人卖给你的关于它的谎言。这可以是一个你突破极限、改变主意或唤醒新版本的自己的时间。所以无论你是独自旅行的老手，还是太紧张而不敢预订你的第一次旅行。我希望你在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Solita》
podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo, and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. From best-selling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table.
播客。如果你的书架和你的推荐页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《Pro Society》，每周播出的播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合思想的女儿、流行文化痴迷者，以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》具有同等讨论价值的人。我是伊莱·拉洛，每周我们都会将书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止谈论的对话联系起来。我得去查查这个故事。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的读书博主到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以讨论的。
It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right of place. Listen to Pro Society on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. The US Open is back. That's right. Two weeks of incredible, exciting tennis. Some outrageous overreactions from players and some hot takes from people who have, let's face it, no idea what they're talking about, but it's okay because I'm here for them and you. I'm Renee Stubbs, and on the Renee Stubbs tennis podcast, I'll be breaking down everything that happens after big matches, who's playing the best tennis,
这就像如果你能在引人入胜的角色中隐藏一些真实的信息，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。在书页间见。美国网球公开赛回来了。没错。两周令人难以置信、激动人心的网球比赛。球员们的一些离谱的过度反应，以及一些人发表的热门观点，让我们面对现实吧，他们根本不知道自己在说什么，但这没关系，因为我在这里为他们和你服务。我是蕾妮·斯塔布斯，在《蕾妮·斯塔布斯网球播客》中，我将剖析大比赛后发生的一切，谁在打出最好的网球，
who looks like they could possibly win this tournament, the surprise runs, the heartbreaking exits, and all the drama that only the US Open can deliver. Coco looking real good. Her serve looks so much smoother than it has in the past. I was really happy to see Eager back to what she looked like a couple of years ago when she was winning dominantly. Listen, I'm going to let Venus decide when she wants to retire.
谁看起来可能赢得这场比赛，惊喜的表现，令人心碎的退出，以及只有美国网球公开赛才能带来的所有戏剧性。可可看起来真的很棒。她的发球看起来比过去顺畅多了。我真的很高兴看到伊加回到了几年前她占据统治地位时的样子。听着，我会让维纳斯决定她什么时候想退役。
I'm going to let the tournaments decide when they don't want to give her a wild card because she still puts bums in seats, she still sells, and people love to see her play. You always say on this show that this is the best predictor of who will do well at the O'S Open. If this is a preview, then we are in for a treat. Listen to the Renee Stubbs Tennis Podcasts on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get you podcasts. So if you are hearing this episode and everything I'm serving to you now and thinking actually, what the fuck are you talking about? and this is not what I expected when I clicked on this episode,
我会让赛事决定他们什么时候不想给她外卡，因为她仍然能吸引观众，她仍然有号召力，人们喜欢看她打球。你总是说在这个节目中，这是谁将在美国网球公开赛上表现出色的最佳预测指标。如果这是一个预览，那么我们将大饱眼福。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《蕾妮·斯塔布斯网球播客》。所以如果你听到这一集，听到我现在为你提供的一切，心想，这到底是什么鬼，这不是我点击这一集时所期望的，
you are absolutely not alone. I think we sometimes hear a name like Freud, and he's so celebrated in psychology, and he's this huge figure, and that lends his theories a lot of legitimacy, and then when you look at these theories, you realize that they are quite odd, and actually that there might not be that much evidence,
你绝对不是一个人。我认为我们有时会听到像弗洛伊德这样的名字，他在心理学界如此受推崇，他是如此巨大的人物，这赋予了他的理论很多合法性，然后当你审视这些理论时，你意识到它们相当奇怪，实际上可能并没有那么多证据，
they were just so outlandish, and of the time, that they've just seemingly carried on. I really want to remind us, Freud existed in a time before rigorous psychological experimentation. And now that we do use processes that involve random sampling, experimental conditions, control groups, ethics committees, that big one, now that we do use those theories, sorry, we do use those methods. We have put the Oedipus complex as a theory through those standards and we've attempted to test it in this rigorous manner. And there has been absolutely no established evidence and no clinical test that can demonstrate
它们只是太离谱了，而且是那个时代的产物，以至于它们似乎一直延续了下来。我真的想提醒我们，弗洛伊德存在于一个没有严谨心理学实验的时代。现在我们确实使用涉及随机抽样、实验条件、对照组、伦理委员会（那个大问题）的过程，现在我们确实使用那些理论，抱歉，我们确实使用那些方法。我们已经将俄狄浦斯情结作为一个理论通过了这些标准，并试图以这种严谨的方式测试它。并且绝对没有任何既定的证据和临床测试可以证明
that the Oedipus complex as a universal or even mildly supported theory exists. Nobody has been able to find wide scale evidence. However, here is what is actually. quite tricky and what people don't always talk about. Freud presented a lot of his ideas as unconscious processes. And he presented a lot of his ideas in a way that meant we cannot falsify them. We cannot prove that they do not occur. This was a very smart thing he did, whether he did it deliberately or not. But the way a lot of Freud's theories are set up is that they are very hard to prove wrong, even if we know they are not right. I mentioned this in the Freud episode,
俄狄浦斯情结作为一个普遍的甚至是被轻微支持的理论存在。没有人能够找到大规模的证据。然而，这里有实际上相当棘手的事情，也是人们并不总是谈论的事情。弗洛伊德将他的许多想法呈现为潜意识过程。他以一种意味着我们无法证伪它们的方式呈现了他的许多想法。我们无法证明它们不会发生。这是一件非常聪明的事情，无论他是故意还是无意。但弗洛伊德的许多理论的设置方式是，即使我们知道它们是不对的，也很难证明它们是错的。我在弗洛伊德那一集中提到过这一点，
but when you have a scientific theory, your scientific theory should ideally make predictions that allow researchers to actually test whether this thing exists or doesn't exist. But when you create a theory that says this is entirely unconscious, therefore if you don't find evidence for it, that proves it. And if you do find evidence for it, that proves it as well. It becomes nearly impossible to decisively conclude whether something is real or not. For example, Freud often treated and worked in the space of dreams and interpretations and projection and all these other things. And the thing was is that if a patient agreed with his interpretation, that would support his theory. but if a patient strongly rejected his interpretation, that could also be interpreted as evidence.
但当你有一个科学理论时，你的科学理论理想情况下应该做出允许研究人员实际测试这个东西是否存在或不存在的预测。但当你创造一个理论说这完全是潜意识的，因此如果你没有找到它的证据，那证明了它。如果你确实找到了它的证据，那也证明了它。几乎不可能果断地得出某事是真实还是不真实的结论。例如，弗洛伊德经常在梦、解释、投射和所有这些其他事物的空间中治疗和工作。事情是，如果患者同意他的解释，那将支持他的理论。但如果患者强烈拒绝他的解释，那也可以被解释为证据。
Then we put this in the kind of way of the Oedipus complex. If you go up to a bunch of people, you do a randomized, controlled study with a thousand people and you say, have you ever experienced any of these feelings towards your own mother that you can remember or acknowledge? If somebody says yes, I do, great, you get to count that as evidence. If somebody says absolutely not, that is so weird, great, you also get to count that as evidence. The reason being, because the Oedipus complex is treated as this unconscious, suppressed, unresolved desire.
然后我们以俄狄浦斯情结的方式来看待这一点。如果你走到一群人面前，你对一千个人进行随机对照研究，你说，你是否曾经记得或承认过对你自己的母亲有过任何这些感觉？如果有人说是的，我有，太好了，你可以将其算作证据。如果有人说绝对没有，那太奇怪了，太好了，你也可以将其算作证据。原因在于，因为俄狄浦斯情结被视为这种潜意识的、被压抑的、未解决的欲望。
And so denying it is just as much evidence of its existence as a, agreeing with it and saying that I've experienced that. So when almost every possible outcome can be interpreted as support for a theory, that theory, just by its basis, is a great one in terms of like, like if you're somebody who never wants to be proven wrong, like Freud. But a terrible one when it comes to actually trying to identify a truth about humanity and a truth about society. Another huge issue with this theory, beyond that, and it's probably something you've been like trying to screaming at me to mention this whole time, I promise you I was getting to it, is the fact that it doesn't acknowledge that homosexuality exists. It doesn't have an explanation
所以否认它和同意它并说我经历过它一样，都是它存在的证据。所以当几乎每一个可能的结果都可以被解释为对一个理论的支持时，那个理论，仅仅基于它的基础，如果你是一个永远不想被证明是错的人，就像弗洛伊德，那它就是一个伟大的理论。但在试图识别关于人类的真相和关于社会的真相时，它就是一个糟糕的理论。这个理论的另一个巨大问题，除此之外，而且这可能是你一直试图对我尖叫让我提到这一点，我向你保证我正要提到它，是它没有承认同性恋的存在。它没有解释
for people who have single parents. It doesn't have an explanation for people who have divorced parents. It doesn't have an explanation for people who are raised in communal societies, people who are transgender, people who are non-binary, people who have same-sex parents. And the biggest blaring omission, it really doesn't mention girls. the Oedipus complex seems to be entirely about boys. The homosexuality thing, I will say, is, like, I think the biggest problem. Like, it just doesn't make any sense, you know, all of those things. I'm like, oh, well, the homosexuality thing.
对于有单亲父母的人。它没有解释对于有离异父母的人。它没有解释对于在公社社会中长大的人、跨性别者、非二元性别者、有同性父母的人。而且最大的明显遗漏，它真的没有提到女孩。俄狄浦斯情结似乎完全是关于男孩的。同性恋的事情，我会说，是，我认为最大的问题。就像，它根本说不通，你知道，所有那些事情。我心想，哦，好吧，同性恋的事情。
But then also the single-parent thing, but then also, like, the divorce parent thing, like, he just didn't have explanations for those things. But when it came to women and all young girls and how they fit into the theory, it gets a whole lot weirder. I know you're probably like, that's impossible. I've just heard you go on and on about this crazy thing. No, it gets a lot weirder. So he proposed that girls initially have a close attachment to their mother,
但还有单亲的事情，但还有，就像，离异父母的事情，就像，他只是对这些事情没有解释。但当涉及到女性和所有年轻女孩以及她们如何融入这个理论时，它变得更加奇怪了。我知道你可能心想，那是不可能的。我刚刚听你喋喋不休地谈论这个疯狂的事情。不，它变得更加奇怪了。所以他提出女孩最初对她们的母亲有亲密的依恋，
which is most children, but during the phallic stage, they supposedly become aware that they do not have a penis. I know, I told you, it was going to get weird. Freud claimed that when women realize, that they go, I don't have a penis. My dad does. My mother doesn't. They get all confused. And they interpret this as a deficiency. And they blame their mother for the fact that they don't have a penis. And they redirect their attention towards their father because they possess something that
这是大多数孩子的情况，但在性器期，她们据称意识到她们没有阴茎。我知道，我告诉过你，它会变得很奇怪。弗洛伊德声称当女性意识到这一点时，她们会说，我没有阴茎。我爸爸有。我母亲没有。她们变得非常困惑。她们将此解释为一种缺陷。她们因为自己没有阴茎而责怪她们的母亲。她们将注意力转向她们的父亲，因为她们拥有某种
that she lacks, i.e. all young girls secretly want a penis. And this creates a concept known as penis envy. That means they hate their mother and they admire their father. Yeah. Yeah. It's crazy. Eventually, like, Freud says that, you know, the girl comes back. She begins to realize she can never get a penis. She identifies with her mother. And she seeks, in his words, symbolic substitutes for the penis, including in Freud's account, the desire to have a baby. and the desire to have a boy. Yeah, all women secretly, all women secretly have penis envy,
她所缺乏的东西，即所有年轻女孩都秘密地想要一个阴茎。这创造了一个被称为“阴茎嫉妒”的概念。这意味着她们恨她们的母亲，崇拜她们的父亲。是的。是的。这太疯狂了。最终，就像，弗洛伊德说，你知道，女孩回来了。她开始意识到她永远无法得到一个阴茎。她认同她的母亲。并且她寻求，用他的话来说，阴茎的象征性替代品，包括在弗洛伊德的叙述中，想要生孩子的欲望。以及想要一个男孩的欲望。是的，所有女性秘密地，所有女性秘密地都有阴茎嫉妒，
and they secretly want to have children to fill that void, specifically boy children. If you've ever, the idea of a boy mom, like this idea of like, oh, I'm a boy mom and like this whole thing online about boy moms,
并且她们秘密地想要孩子来填补那个空白，特别是男孩。如果你曾经，男孩妈妈的想法，就像这种想法，哦，我是男孩妈妈，以及网上关于男孩妈妈的这一切，
Freud would have a field day with that. That actually provides a lot of evidence for his theory, which is crazy. like that's crazy that, yeah, women on TikTok and like on Instagram being like, I love my, I'm like, I love being a boy mom and like, oh my God, I love my son more than I've ever loved any man. And I don't know what I'm going to do when he like, he loves another woman. I might just kill her, like all those crazy things.
弗洛伊德会对此大做文章。这实际上为他的理论提供了很多证据，这太疯狂了。就像那太疯狂了，是的，TikTok和Instagram上的女性说，我爱我的，我心想，我喜欢成为一个男孩妈妈，就像，哦天哪，我爱我的儿子胜过我爱过的任何男人。我不知道当他爱上另一个女人时我会怎么办。我可能会杀了她，就像所有那些疯狂的事情。
He's literally like, not proving, but providing evidence for this crazy whack job theory that Freud had about women. There is another term, though, that we use sometimes that describes this. It's called the Electra Complex. This is actually labelled by Carl Jung, who was Freud's predecessor. But Freud didn't want a separate term for what happened to women in this period. He liked Oedipus Complex. He just kind of thought that women, like, it was kind of an afterthought for him.
他简直就像是，不是证明，而是为弗洛伊德关于女性的这个疯狂的怪胎理论提供了证据。不过，我们有时使用的另一个术语描述了这个。它被称为“厄勒克特拉情结”。这实际上是由卡尔·荣格标记的，他是弗洛伊德的前任。但弗洛伊德不想为女性在这个时期发生的事情使用单独的术语。他喜欢俄狄浦斯情结。他只是有点认为女性，就像，对他来说这是一种事后的想法。
So these ideas are naturally crazy. Let's just call it as we see it. And they were naturally challenged at the time within the psychoanalytic, like psychoanalytic community, specifically by a woman called Karen Horny. She was a German psychoanalyst operating at the same time as Freud. And she basically heard this theory and was like, that is insane. Do you know women? Do you speak to women who aren't your patients or like your daughter? Like that's, this is, you've interpreted this whole thing through a male-centered lens, one that is probably inaccurate as well. She suggested that rather than perceiving women, rather than women perceiving their
所以这些想法本质上是疯狂的。让我们直言不讳。它们在当时在精神分析社区内自然受到了挑战，特别是被一位名叫卡伦·霍妮的女性。她是一位与弗洛伊德同时期的德国精神分析学家。她基本上听到了这个理论，心想，那太疯狂了。你了解女性吗？你和不是你的病人或你的女儿的女性交谈过吗？就像那是，这是，你通过一个以男性为中心的视角解释了这一切，这个视角可能也是不准确的。她建议，与其感知女性，与其说女性感知她们的
own bodies as defective as a result of some apparent. an envy for men, it's not envy that they are experiencing towards the penis. Women are experiencing envy around the access to social freedom and independence and authority and power that was available to men at the time. To her, it was just insane to say that all women secretly wanted a penis because they were sexually jealous and attracted to their father. She basically said, no, this is again, all part of socialization. And it's all part of girls and boys learning at a critical age around six or seven, they start to really realize what is my role in society because of my gender. What is expected of me? What is and isn't correct in the eyes of society?
将自己的身体视为某种缺陷的结果。这并不是她们对阴茎产生了嫉妒，女性所经历的嫉妒是围绕着当时男性所拥有的社会自由、独立、权威和权力。对她来说，认为所有女性都暗中想要一个阴茎，仅仅是因为她们性嫉妒并被父亲吸引，这简直是疯了。她基本上说，不，这同样是社会化的一部分。这都是女孩和男孩在六七岁这个关键年龄段学习的一部分，他们开始真正意识到，由于我的性别，我在社会中的角色是什么？对我有什么期望？在社会眼中，什么是正确的，什么是不正确的？
And how do I adjust that with my own sense of self? That possessiveness as well of parents that Freud saw as indication of sexual desire, unconscious sexual attraction, it's also just really normal when you're a kid. Do you know what I mean? Like, it's really normal when you're a child to maybe favor one parent or to maybe identify more with one parent based on your gender. And it's really normal for children to try and make sense of relationships through the relationship that their parents have and say, oh, I want to marry somebody like mommy because, well, they've only probably been this close to one example of a relationship their whole lives. It's really quite normal for children to feel like they want more attention from their
我该如何将其与我自己的自我意识相协调？弗洛伊德将父母的这种占有欲视为性欲、潜意识性吸引力的表现，但这在孩子身上其实非常正常。你明白我的意思吗？就像，作为一个孩子，根据你的性别可能更偏爱某一位家长，或者可能与某一位家长认同感更强，这真的很正常。孩子们试图通过父母之间的关系来理解人际关系，并说“哦，我想嫁给像妈妈那样的人”，这也很正常，因为他们一生中可能只接触过这一种亲密关系的例子。孩子们觉得他们想要从父母那里得到更多关注，这真的很正常。
mother or from their father, whoever is the primary caregiver. and to see the other parent as competition because children are greedy and children are 100% reliant on their caregiver. So anything that feels like that's going to take them away from that, obviously they're going to react accordingly. So these days the theory is seen as a bit of a joke and seen as a little bit funny, right? It's like taking, it's like somebody being like, well, how are apples made? in coming up with this like elaborate idea of like somebody sewing an apple to a tree.
或者从父亲那里，无论谁是主要照顾者。并将另一位家长视为竞争对手，因为孩子是贪婪的，而且孩子百分之百依赖他们的照顾者。所以任何让他们觉得会把自己从照顾者身边带走的事情，他们显然会做出相应的反应。所以现在，这个理论被视为一个笑话，被认为有点滑稽，对吧？这就像有人问“苹果是怎么造出来的？”，然后想出一个复杂的想法，比如有人把苹果缝在树上。
Like we know the children go through these things. Is it because of this weird whack-dob idea that they are somehow unconsciously desiring their parents? Probably not. And it was a real big reason why at the time Freud got into a lot of fights and a lot of professional arguments with his colleagues, including his predecessor to Carl Jung, who basically stopped talking to him because he was like, you need to chill out. Your theories are a little bit perverted. And also, what?
我们知道孩子们会经历这些事情。这是因为那种奇怪的、疯狂的想法，即他们潜意识里渴望自己的父母吗？可能不是。这就是为什么当时弗洛伊德与他的同事们发生了很多争吵和专业上的争论，包括他的前任卡尔·荣格，他基本上不再与弗洛伊德说话，因为他觉得“你需要冷静点。你的理论有点变态。而且，还有，为什么？”
Like, also, why? You know, like, they just were a bit like, you need to just maybe go for a walk and actually maybe speak to women a bit more that aren't just your patients and also maybe not make everything about sex. So with that being said, does this theory have any lasting value?
就像，还有，为什么？你知道，他们只是觉得“你可能需要去散散步，也许真的应该多和那些不仅仅是你的病人的女性谈谈，也许不要把一切都归结为性”。话虽如此，这个理论还有任何持久的价值吗？
As a literal universal theory of childhood development, no, it does not. have any value because it excludes a whole lot of the diversity that exists in real families in our society today and it just actually can't explain it. It can only explain a very, very narrow, very narrow section of society in a way that is also probably not true. Besides that, the theory has an enormous historical and cultural impact. I think because of how shocking it is, you know, this whole idea is really memorable. It challenges deeply held assumptions about innocence, about family bonds, about morality, about sex.
作为一种字面上的儿童发展普遍理论，不，它没有任何价值，因为它排除了当今社会真实家庭中存在的巨大多样性，而且它实际上根本无法解释这些。它只能以一种可能并不真实的方式解释社会中非常、非常狭窄的一部分。除此之外，该理论具有巨大的历史和文化影响。我认为正是因为它太令人震惊了，你知道，整个想法非常令人难忘。它挑战了关于纯真、家庭纽带、道德和性的根深蒂固的假设。
And I think the shock factor behind this theory is what makes it and continues to keep it present in popular culture and in academic debates to this day. If we were going to give Freud any of his flowers, and if there was anything good to take from this, I will say he did acknowledge that humans and children are complex. And he did acknowledge that children can have conflicting ideas, or complex ideas, which at the time wasn't that widely held, right? He really did, he saw people as acting irrationally, he saw people as acting imperfectly, and he kind of saw the fact that children do start to have their own personalities and desires in a way that clinicians
我认为这个理论背后的冲击因素是它至今仍存在于流行文化和学术辩论中的原因。如果我们想给弗洛伊德任何赞誉，如果说从中能学到什么好的东西，我会说他确实承认人类和儿童是复杂的。他确实承认孩子们可以有相互冲突的想法，或者复杂的想法，这在当时并不是被广泛接受的观点，对吧？他确实看到了人们行为的不理性，他看到了人们行为的不完美，他某种程度上看到了孩子们开始以一种临床医生当时可能并没有广泛讨论的方式拥有自己的个性和欲望的事实。
probably weren't really talking about that widely at the time. So these days, we've cherry-picked, we've refined, we've developed the idea, and we've just created a bit more of a robust theory. We've come a long way since like 100 years ago where this was like the best thing we could come up with. Nowadays we understand that children go through these different developmental periods. They naturally become more curious about themselves, including their body, including their anatomy. And whilst that is happening, they also become more aware of the social dynamics surrounding them. And so whilst these things may look like they're happening at the same time, time or look like they're causing one another. That is not the case. It is just the pathway
所以现在，我们已经去其糟粕，取其精华，我们完善并发展了这个想法，创造了一个更稳健的理论。自100年前我们能想出这个作为最好的理论以来，我们已经走了很长一段路。如今我们明白，孩子们会经历这些不同的发展时期。他们自然会对自身变得更加好奇，包括他们的身体，包括他们的解剖结构。当这种情况发生时，他们也会变得更加意识到周围的社会动态。因此，虽然这些事情看起来像是同时发生的，或者看起来像是互为因果。事实并非如此。这只是人们经历的路径。
that people take. Multiple things are happening in the developmental life of a child at the same time. That is all I have for you today. If you had no idea what this was about, I'm, I feel like I need to apologize. I feel like you've come into this being like, oh my God, yeah, I'm just going to listen to this at the gym, just going to listen to this in the car with my parents or my friends. And suddenly you're like, oh my God, why does she keep saying sex, an unconscious desire, and penis and envy, penis envy. So I'm sorry, I still hope you learned something from this episode. I think it's a really good thing to know.
在孩子的发展生活中，多重事物同时发生。这就是我今天想说的全部内容。如果你完全不知道这是关于什么的，我，我觉得我需要道歉。我觉得你进来的时候是想，“哦天哪，是的，我只是要在健身房听这个，只是要在车里和父母或朋友一起听这个。”然后突然你觉得，“哦天哪，为什么她一直说性、潜意识欲望、阴茎和嫉妒、阴茎嫉妒。”所以我很抱歉，我仍然希望你从这一集中学到了一些东西。我认为了解这一点是一件非常好的事情。
And once you start understanding this, you can kind of catch certain jokes that you see in pop culture, you start being able to apply it to like funny things that you see. So, yes, I hope you learnt. I hope you were shocked, but not unhappy with the, with the, contents of this episode. I want to thank our research would Libby for helping us with this episode today. If you did not know already, you can watch all of our episodes on Netflix. Not this episode. I don't think it would have gotten past their standards. I don't think they would have let me do an episode on this, but all of our non-bonous episodes of which there are a lot are now on Netflix.
一旦你开始理解这一点，你就能捕捉到你在流行文化中看到的一些笑话，你开始能够将其应用到你看到的有趣的事情上。所以，是的，我希望你学到了。我希望你感到震惊，但对这一集的内容并不反感。我要感谢我们的研究员利比今天帮助我们完成了这一集。如果你还不知道，你可以在Netflix上观看我们所有的剧集。不是这一集。我不认为它能通过他们的标准。我不认为他们会让我做一集关于这个的内容，但我们所有非奖励剧集（其中有很多）现在都在Netflix上。
Go give it a look. Go give it a watch. You can also follow us on Instagram, substack. Everything you need to know will be in the description, including an entire. entire playlist of every single one of our bonus episodes, have a look down there, you'll find it, and you can listen to some of our other ones. I promise they're a lot less raunchy than this. But thank you for listening all the way to the end. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus, or this random dude is offering.
去看看吧。去观看吧。你也可以在Instagram、Substack上关注我们。你需要知道的一切都在描述中，包括我们每一集奖励剧集的完整播放列表，往下面看，你会找到它，你可以听听我们其他的剧集。我保证它们比这一集要正经得多。但感谢你一直听到最后。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，善待自己。我们很快就会再聊。在新的播客Solita中，我们分享作为女性独自旅行的混乱现实。我可以等四个小时等下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙提议。
me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就说“是”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听Solita。我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的事情中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会与经历过不可思议的事情的幸存者在一起，被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。
These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture, with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed.
这些是关于如何活着走出来的故事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊，适合任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》具有同等讨论价值的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、书评创作者和大量的过度思考观点一起，连接书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴。是的，我着迷了。我着迷了。
Listen to Pro Society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So, like, by Asia 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is Therapy for Black Girls. We spend our surviving middle school run getting into what's happening inside your kid's brain, the group chat, and their friendships, and what you can do about it. Your child is not doing this on purpose. That's the kind of perspective we've been pulling from the psychologists and psychiatrists who studied this for a living. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to Decoding Women's Health. I'm Dr. Elizabeth Pointer, chair of Women's Health.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Pro Society》。所以，大概到11岁左右，至少70%的孩子有手机。我是乔伊博士，这是《黑人女孩的治疗》。我们花时间在初中生存中，深入探讨你孩子大脑中正在发生的事情、群聊和他们的友谊，以及你能为此做些什么。你的孩子不是故意这样做的。这就是我们从研究这一领域的心理学家和精神科医生那里获得的视角。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《黑人女孩的治疗》。欢迎来到《解码女性健康》。我是伊丽莎白·波因特博士，女性健康主席。
and gynecology at the Atria Health Institute in New York City. I'll be talking to top researchers and clinicians and bringing vital information about midlife women's health directly to you. A hundred percent of women go through menopause. Even if it's natural, why should we suffer through it? Listen to decoding women's help with Dr. Elizabeth Pointer on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及纽约市Atria健康研究所的妇科。我将与顶尖的研究人员和临床医生交谈，并将关于中年女性健康的重要信息直接带给你。百分之百的女性都会经历更年期。即使它是自然的，我们为什么要忍受它？在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·波因特博士的《解码女性健康》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。